die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend und Willkommen an
meiner Seite ist für den Sport Norbert
Lehmann ein schönen guten Abend auch von
mir und das sind die Nachrichtenthemen
dieses
freitags Friedhof Mittelmeer so viele
Migranten wie seit Jahren nicht
riskieren diese fluchtrutee und viele
kommen bei der Überfahrt ums Leben
kaufen und essen nach Maß eine
Aktionswoche will zeigen wie die
massenweise Verschwendung von
Lebensmitteln vermieden werden
kann das Beste im TV beim Deutschen
Fernsehpreis darf sich das ZDF über die
meisten Auszeichnungen freuen und bullli
Herbich über die Ehrung seines
Lebenswerks während die EU um eine
Verschärfung des Asylrechts ringt
schlägt das flüchtlingshilfswerk der en
Nationen Alarm es brauche Garantien für
die Wahrung der Menschenrechte und es
brauche verstärkte such und
Rettungsaktionen auf dem
Mittelmeer denn die Situation entwickel
sich dramatisch mehr als 2500 Menschen
sind seit Jahresbeginn gestorben oder
gelten als vermisst fast 840 mehr als im
gleichen Zeitraum des Vorjahres die Zahl
der angekommenen Migranten liegt bei
rund
186000 Italien ist dabei das Haupt
fast 133 000 Menschen sind es dort nur
über das Mittelmeer 83% mehr als
2022 wie Italien mit dieser Situation
umgeht zeigt Andreas Postel Katania
Sizilien eines von zwei
erstaufnahmelagern in das die
bootsmigranten von Lampedusa gebracht
werden bevor sie in die Regionen
weiterverteilt
werden sie suchen hier erst einmal Ruhe
denn sie kommen aus schwierigen
Situationen haben schreckliche Dinge
erlebt
Mitte September kamen binnen weniger
Tage 8500 Menschen über den gefährlichen
seeeweg nach Lampedusa der Hotspot
völlig überlastet die italienische Insel
rief den Notstand
aus es war nicht gut die Wahrheit ist
nicht schön ich möchte nicht darüber
reden aber langsam geht es mir
besser agun ist in einer Einrichtung für
unbegleitete Jugendliche in Katania
untergekommen und absolviert mit den
anderen ein
Integrationsprogramm ich möchte Konditor
werden mache jetzt ein Praktikum Schule
und Arbeit zusammen morgens arbeite ich
und nachmittags gehe ich zur
Schule als unbegleitete Minderjährige
haben sie Bleiberecht viele der
Lampedusa Migranten wollen nicht in
Italien bleiben sondern weiter nach
Frankreich oder Deutschland pozalo
Sizilien dies ist das erste der neuen
sogenannten rückführungszentren die
Italiens ultrarechte Regierung im ganzen
Land errichten will derzeit belegt mit
150 Familien deren asl geprüft wird der
Bürgermeister von pozalo vom
sozialdemokratischen PD hält davon gar
nichts wenn wir innerhalb eines Jahres
150 000 Ankünfte haben von denen wir
1000 abgelehnte Asylbewerber bis zur
Abschiebung einsperren dann löst das
meiner Meinung nach nicht das Problem
ich halte diese Zentren für nutzlos
Integration statt Abschottung ist sein
Credo mehr finanzielle Unterstützung ist
das was er sich
wünscht fragen wir nach bei Isabel
Schäfers in Brüssel die EU ringt gerade
um einen Krisenmechanismus wenn ein Land
von besonders hohen Flüchtlingszahlen
überfordert ist doch da stellt sich
jetzt ausgerechnet Italien quer warum ja
Italien hat natürlich eigentlich ein
sehr großes Interesse an diesem
Krisenmechanismus und eben der
Möglichkeit wenn besonders viele
Flüchtlinge ankommen die Standards etwa
bei der Unterbringung zu senken aber um
dem zustimmen zu können hatte
Deutschland gewisse humanitäre Standards
reinverhandeln wollen und dadurch lagen
wieder alle Details auf dem Tisch und da
kam Italien plötzlich mit dem Thema
Seenotrettung um die Ecke das spielt
zwar bei dieser Verordnung nur eine
untergeordnete Rolle aber Italien
versucht derzeit bei jeder Gelegenheit
gegen Seenotretter vorzugehen und ist ja
auch nicht besonders begeistert davon
dass Deutschland zivile seenotrettungs
Organisationen unterstützt und so kam es
eben zu der Situation dass die deutsche
Innenministerin bereits von einer
politischen Einigung sprach aber dann
relativ schnell klar wurde dass das
ganze noch nicht in trockenen Tüchern
ist ob es da jetzt eine Lösung geben
wird bei dieser krisenverordnung in den
kommenden Tagen das wird man sehen aber
angesichts der hohen Zahlen von
Flüchtlingen und Toten auf dem
Mittelmeer ist auf jeden Fall klar dass
das Thema Seenotrettung der EU erhalten
bleiben wird danke schön für diese
Information aus Brüssel Isabel Schäfers
war
das mit Sorge schauen viele in der EU
auf die Parlamentswahl in der Slowakei
morgen das Ergebnis könnte auch die
Ukraine Politik der EU
beeinflussen die Slowakei mit über 5
Millionen Einwohnern liegt am Rand der
EU Nachbarin der Ukraine und fest an
ihrer Seite bislang denn im Wahlkampf
punktet er Robert fizzo mit seiner
prorussischen Haltung der Sozialdemokrat
und Verbündete des ungarischen
Ministerpräsidenten Orban verspricht
seinen Wählern die militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine zu beenden
aus Bratislava Britta
Hilpert diese Szene kennzeichnet den
Stil des slowakischen Wahlkampfs während
einer K
ein Exminister und ein
expremier der politische Wahlkampf ist
harsch und handfest und außerdem voller
proussischer Desinformation die er für
sich nutzt robert fizo ist
Favorit die EU übernimmt blind die
Sanktionspolitik der USA wenn meine
parteis mehr an der Regierung ist
stoppen wir jede militärische Hilfe für
die
Ukraine wäre erstaunlich er war 2018
premier alsord erschütterte Jan kujak
und seine Verlobte mussten sterben weil
der investigativreporter Verbindung
zwischen Mafia und Regierung aufdeckte
die Slowaken gingen zu Tausenden auf die
Straße erzwangen fizus Rücktritt doch
folgende Regierungen verursachten Chaos
Pandemie Krieg und Inflation untergruben
das Vertrauen der Bürger in die
Demokratie rechtsnationalisten
erstarkten und sind mögliche
Koalitionspartner für fizzo erführt mit
rund 18% fast gleich auf ist mich
liberaler
Europapolitiker wir können wählen das
Chaos der letzten Jahre die Rückehr der
Vergangenheit oder eine normale und
anständige
Politik es geht auch darum welche
außenpolitischen Freundschaften die
Slowakei in Zukunft pflegt z.B zum
Ungarn Viktor Orban es ist eine
Richtungswahl für die Slowakei und für
Europa Robert fizo als Regierungschef
das wäre wie ein zweiter Viktor Orban in
der EU mit mit möglichen Blockaden bei
Migration bei russlandsanktionen und bei
der Ukraine
Unterstützung die Zahl der Arbeitslosen
in Deutschland ist im September nur
leicht gesunken die Herbstbelebung Falle
dieses Jahr vergleichsweise gering aus
so die Bundesagentur für Arbeit demnach
waren diesen Monat
2627 000 Menschen ohne Job das sind 69
000 weniger als im August die
Arbeitslosenquote liegt bei
5,7% im Vergleich zum Vorjahreszeitpunkt
sind
141 000 mehr Menschen
arbeitslos in Bayern und Hessen wird
gewählt am 8 Oktober heute haben wir ein
Politbarometer extra dazu schauen wir
erst nach Hessen hier wollen nach der
Wahl gleich drei Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten in die Staatskanzlei
einziehen für die CDU geht erstmals
Amtsinhaber Boris Rhein ins Rennen die
Grünen setzen auf Wirtschaft Minister t
alvasir und die SPD auf
bundesinnenministerin nenn sie Feser
nach den neuen Zahlen des
politbarometers kann die Union zulegen
und ist mit 32% klar vorn Grüne und SPD
kämen jeweils auf 17 die AFD auf 16% für
FDP linke und Freie Wähler wird es knapp
Peter
Wagner auf den letzten Meter noch
klingen putzen borisin unterwegs im
Haustür im südhässischen Gersheim
zusammen mit der CDU
Fraktionschefin ger ih Kanda
vstell 15 Punkte vor den anderen
Spitzenkandidaten der amtierende
Ministerpräsident könnte eigentlich
entspannt sein ich glaube das wird immer
eine knappe Sache eine Ampel ist immer
möglich in der Schwankungsbreite von
solchen Umfragen und deswegen muss man
wirklich um die letzte Stimme auch noch
kämpfen kämpfen muss auch nen f zuletzt
seit an seit am Samstag mit Kanzler
Scholz in baunertal die
bundesinnenministerin kann von ihrer
Bekanntheit nicht profitieren hofft aber
noch auf die kertwende in dem Moment wo
wir alle über Hessen reden wird es eine
ganz andere Aufmerksamkeit in Hessen
dafür geben dass man auch nach 25 Jahren
CDU Regierung die einfach die
Zukunftsthemen haben liegen lassen dann
auch sich für uns entscheiden können t
alvasir wollte Hessens erster grüner
Ministerpräsident werden die schlechte
Berlin ampelstimmung lässt diesen Traum
wohl platzen das grüne Urgestein blickt
staatsmännisch auf künftige Koalitionen
dann werden wir sehen wie das
Wahlergebnis ist dann werden alle
demokratischen Parteien miteinander
reden und am Ende ist es ganz ganz
wichtig dass man eine stabile und
verlässliche Regierung für die nächsten
5 Jahre bekommt die FDP bewegt sich
Richtung 5% Hürde und droht wie die
Linke aus dem hässischen Landtag zu
fliegen es sieht danach aus als könnte
die CDU sich am Tag nach der mal den
nächsten Koalitionspartner zwischen grün
und rot
aussuchen weitere Zahlen vom
Politbarometer extra hat Matthias vnhof
guten Abend guten Abend wen wünschen
sich denn die Hessen an der
Regierungsspitze da liegt der CDU
Amtsinhaber rein gegenüber den
Herausforderern von Grünen und SPD VN
44% wünschen sich weiter Boris rin als
Regierungschef 31% seinen FZE von den
Grünen Tarek alvasir noch größer ist
Sprung auf SPD Spitzenkandidatin nency
fäer 55 zu
21% die Hessen lehnen übrigens
mehrheitlich alle denkbaren Koalitionen
ab und wovon hängt ihre Wahlentscheidung
ab von der Politik im Land sagt eine
Mehrheit von 52% vom Bund immerhin
44% in Bayern ist die Landespolitik noch
deutlicher entscheidend 60 Z
36% genau auch die Bayern wählen am 8
Oktober dort regiert seit fast 66 Jahren
die CSU und wird das vermutlich auch
weiter tun können ja in Bayern liegt die
CSU deutlich vorn wenn auch mit einem
für sie schwachen wert wenn am Sonntag
schon Wahl wäre käme die CSU auf 36% die
Grünen auf 16 Freie Wähler
15-1 im Vergleich zu vor 3 Wochen AFD 14
+ 2 SPD 9 FDP
4%. die meisten Bayern wünschen sich
dass Markus Söder Ministerpräsident
bleibt aber mit welchem Partner eine
Mehrheit von 46% findet eine Fortsetzung
der Koalition mit den Freien Wählern gut
Bündnisse mit SPD oder grünen finden
dagegen die meisten
schlecht soweit die Zahlen aus Hessen
und Bayern genau Sonntag in einer Woche
wissen wir mehr danke schön Matthias
fornof alle Zahlen vom Politbarometer
extra gibt's jederzeit online unter
freute.de das so genannte heizungsgesetz
musste schon einiges an Streitigkeiten
und Hürden überwinden heute nun die
letzte der Bundesrat hat zugestimmt
damit kann das gebäudeenergiegesetz im
Januar in Kraft treten es soll den
Klimaschutz bei Gebäuden beschleunigen
so wird z.B der Einbau klimaschonender
Heizungen finanziell gefördert beim
Klimaschutz setzt die Bundesregierung
vor allem auf erneuerbare Energien sie
konnten in diesem Jahr bislang
52% also mehr als die Hälfte der des
stromverbrauchsdecken das sind 5% Punkte
mehr im Vergleich zum Vorjahreszeitraum
vor allem
Fotovoltaikanlagen leisten einen immer
größeren Beitrag zur
Stromversorgung sie bekämpfen sich auf
offener Straße unbeteeiligte geraten
immer wieder ins Kreuzfeuer und Sterben
Schweden hat seit Jahren ein Problem mit
Bandenkriminalität in diesem Monat
eskalierte die Gewalt deshalb greift die
schwedische Regierung zu einer
drastischen Maßnahme
das Militär soll helfen Heike Kuse mit
Einzelheiten schon wieder eine Explosion
schon wieder ein Anschlag einer gäng in
einem Wohngebiet in upslala stabb
gestern eine 25-jährige Frau laut
Polizei eine völlig Unbeteiligte alleine
in diesem Monat wurden außerdem Menschen
bei Auseinandersetzung verfeindeter
Banden erschossen die Gewalt eskaliert
und das seit Jahren der Regierungschef
kündigte gestern Abend außergewöhnliches
an wir werden sehen wie gut die
nationalen Verteidigungskräfte der
Polizei bei ihrer Arbeit gegen
kriminelle Banden helfen können ich
hoffe dass alle Parteien im schwedischen
Parlament mitmachen werden um die
einschneidenden Maßnahmen die getroffen
werden müssen zu
unterstützen laut schwedischer
Verfassung ist der Einsatz des Militärs
im eigenen Land in besonderen
Situationen möglich wenn die Mehrheit
des Parlaments
zustimmt das ist beides gut und schlecht
mit dem Militär wir haben Witze gemacht
das Militär aber nun sind wir an dem
Punkt wo es wohl nicht mehr anders
geht die Gewalt schafft eine unsichere
Gesellschaft meiner Meinung nach viele
lassen ihre Kinder nicht mehr auf die
Straße die Gangs werben oft
Minderjährige aus Einwanderervierteln an
die dann im Kampf um den Drogenhandel
töten und getötet werden laut
Presseberichten vermuten die Behörden
die Anführer der kriminellen Banden im
Ausland einen davon in der Türkei er
soll sich kurdischer Fuchs nennen die
mit Rechtsregierung will nun auch das
Strafrecht und das Asylrecht massiv
verschärfen die Warenhauskette mainre
ist seit Jahren in Schieflage jetzt hat
das Unternehmen Insolvenz angemeldet
allerdings in Eigenverwaltung so dass
der Geschäftsbetrieb weiterläuft und
Gespräche zur Übernahme einiger
Standorte geführt werden können von der
Insolvenz sind mehr als 5000 Mitarbeiter
in 62 Märkten
betroffen der apfelfleckig die Konserve
abgelaufen die Portion im Restaurant zu
groß in Deutschland landen jedes Jahr R
11 Millionen Tonnen Lebensmittel im Müll
ein geringer Teil der Abfälle entsteht
schon bei der Erzeugung deutlich mehr
fällt bei der Verarbeitung bei der
Gastronomie und im Handel an aber den
größten Teil der Lebensmittel
59% werfen private Haushalte Weg eine
bundesweite Aktionswoche soll jetzt
zeigen vieles davon ist ver
Feierabend auf dem Mainzer Marktplatz
die drei von der Initiative food sharing
müssen jetzt Gas geben denn die
Standbetreiber bauen schnell ab
Hallo food sharing haben Sie was zu
retten da jawoh habe ich
danke die Mission Lebensmittel retten
die Ehrenamtlichen sammeln ein was
keiner mehr haben will denn gekauft wird
auf dem Markt und auch in Supermärkten
in der Regel nur was Mar los
ist kommt normalerweise in den Müll das
Schicksal vieler
Lebensmittel auch zu Hause kann jeder
Einzelne etwas tun z.B bedarfsgerecht
und gezielt einkaufen und dann richtig
lagern verschiedene Zonen im Kühlschrank
haben andere Temperaturen und die
kälteste Zone ist gerade die über dem
Gemüsefach und da sollten leicht
verderbliche Lebensmittel liegen wie z.B
diese Wurst die wird eher schneller
schlecht wenn ich sie in der Tür lagere
denn da ist es am wärmsten also legen
wir die mal hierhin und das
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum darf auch mal
verstreichen bis zu diesem Datum ist das
Lebensmittel noch ganz genauso wie der
Hersteller es eingefüllt hat das heißt
aber automatisch danach ist es nicht
sofort schlecht aber Vorsicht ans
Verbrauchsdatum bei empfindlichen
Lebensmitteln wie Fisch sollte man sich
besser halten in Mainz verteilen die
Ehrenamtlichen von food sharing die
geretteten Lebensmittel Obst Gemüse oder
Brot ein groß Teil bringen sie zu
sogenannten Verteilern an denen sich
jeder frei bedienen kann der Rest geht
an Bedürftige oder auch einfach an
Verwandte und Bekannte hauptsache es
landet nichts in der
Tonne großer Jubel gestern Abend bei der
ZDF Sport Crew für ihre
wmberichterstattung aus Qatar wurden sie
mit dem Deutschen Fernsehpreis
ausgezeichnet bei der Verleihung in Köln
gab es viele stolze Gesichter mit sieben
von insgesamt 30 Preisen das ZDF Sieger
des Abends Ina Baltes hat
Details viel glämmer und Glitzer an
diesem Abend im Kölner Industriegebiet
drinen im Saal ist der Preis dieses Jahr
sehr politisch bester Fernsehfilm ist
die Bürgermeisterin das Thema
[Applaus]
aktuell Anna Schut kämpft als
Lokalpolitikerin gegen Hass und Hetze
die meisten Preise gehen an das ztf auch
der für die beste Sportsendung die
Berichterstattung zur fußballwm in
Qatar diese WM war eigentlich ein
Albtraum ein Albtraum von vorne bis
hinten und dem sind wir irgendwie
gerecht geworden und haben aber trotzdem
den Sport nicht vergessen eine
begeisterte Dankesrede halten die
Kaulitz Brüder Gewinner in der Kategorie
beste Unterhaltungsshow für that's my
Jam auf RTL
plus also ohne Scheiß wir haben gar
nichts vorbereitet wir sind gerade total
überwältigt also wir haben da niemals
mit gerechnet gewürdigt wurde auch der
freie Reporter Arn Ginzel für seine
Berichterstattung für das ZDF aus der
Ukraine ich war selber dort als der
Krieg begonnen hat und sowas lässt ein
nicht los SAS begleitet ein natürlich
auch bester Mehrteiler der Schwarm in
der internationalen ZDF Serie mit
spektakulären bildernhrt sich die Natur
gegen den
Menschen Preis nach Hause Michael Bull
Herbich seine Werke so die Jury haben
Film und Fernsehgeschichte
geschrieben sehr schön und Glückwunsch
an den Sport ja danke gebe ich gerne an
die Cre weiter ja und weiter geht's mit
dem Fußball buundesliga spitzenpiel
morgen abend Leipzig gegen München heute
Nachmittag der Paukenschlag RB trennt
sich von Max EB dem
sportgeschäftsführer Max wurde immer
wieder mit den Bayern in Verbindung
gebracht nach nicht einem Jahr nun der
Rausschmiss des sportvorstands Grund
fehlendes commitment mangelnde
Identifikation mit dem Verein viel
Unruhe vor dem Spitzenspiel in dem
Leipzig die Münchner eigentlich ärgern
wollte die beiden letzten Duelle gewann
RB doch Tabellenführer Bayern wird sich
nicht so einfach von der Spitze kicken
lassen die Verletzungssorgen um ihre
Abwehr und auch Thomas Müller sind wohl
im Griff so braucht Leipzigs Trainer
Rose jeden einzelnen im Team doch Timo
Werner wird wegen Rückenproblemen
fehlen die uea will Nachwuchsteams aus
Russland wieder mitspielen lassen dafür
sprachen sich auch die deutschen
exekutivkomitemitglieder Watzke und
romenige aus andere Nationalverbände
dagegen drohen mit boikott Streit gibt
es auch im internationalen
paralympischen
Komitee Sportlerinnen und Sportler aus
Russland dürfen bei den Paralympics in
Paris im nächsten Jahr wieder dabei sein
das hat die IPC Generalversammlung in
bachreien beschlossen 74 Verbände
stimmten für das Ende des
komplettausschlusses Russlands 65
darunter der deutsche Behinderten
Sportbund waren dagegen das war kein
guter Tag für die paralympische Werte
Gemeinschaft aber wir müssen auch zur
Kenntnis nehmen dass in Asien Afrika und
Teilen Südamerikas Werte anders
definiert werden Russland kann
Einzelsportler unter neutraler Flagge
entsenden der paralympische Beschluss
hat auch Signalwirkung für die noch
ausstehende IOC Entscheidung zu
Russland furioser auftagt beim Rider Cup
dem golfduell zwischen Europa und den
USA in Rom unter dem Jubel Tausender
Fans gewann das Team Europa um John RAM
und Rory McElroy alle vier
vormittagsduelle das gab's noch nie und
auch in den vier nachmittagsduellen zog
die USA den kürzeren seinhalb zu
eineinhalb der
Punktestand vormittags und
nachmittagsduelle ist auch hübsch vielen
Dank das Wochenende startet im Südosten
mit Schauern sonst ist es oft freundlich
die hat gleich Christa aben Christian
sieers begrüßt sie um 10 im heute
journal machen sie sich ein schönes
Wochenende wir sind morgen wieder da auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend Morgen
verabschiedet sich der September
erbrachte mehr Sommer als Herbst mit
fast 4° mehr als im langjährigen Mittel
wird er mit großem Abstand der wärmste
der messgeschichte und der zweitonnigste
mit plus 65%. außerdem fiel auch nur
knapp die Hälfte des regensolls warum
nun wir hatten sehr viel stabilen
Hochdruckeinfluss und nur wenige Tiefs
aktuell liegt doch mal eine schwache
Kaltfront über dem Land die in der Nacht
in den Südosten vorankommt dahinter kann
es auch mal auflockern im Westen bildet
sich stellenweise Nebel die Temperaturen
sinken auf 15° an der See und A gr in
den westlichen Mittelgebirgen morgen
steigen dann die Werte auf 18° an den
Küsten und 24° am oberrein und das wird
sich Kühler anfühlen als zuletzt ist es
aber natürlich nicht ist es immer noch
warm dazu gibt es im Südosten anfangs
noch etwas Regen der nachmittags dann
abzieht dann löst sich auch der Nebel im
Westen auf und Wolken und blauer Himmel
wechseln sich ab im Norden gibt's einen
frischen westlichen Wind dann startet
der Oktober so wie der September endete
nämlich eigentlich sommerlich im Norden
ist es zwar etwas unbeständiger im Süden
gibt es aber viel Sonne und noch mal an
die 30° und damit auf Wiedersehen